okay Oh Oh hello
[ __ ] it I got this hey everybody there's
so much stuff happening this morning we
got a bunch of Thor infinity war stuff
to talk about
and supposedly Disney might be buying
Fox in their film library in addition to
a bunch of TV show stuff too meaning
that we might actually get an x-men
marvel crossover that people have been
asking for since the beginning of time
so if you're just finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's so much stuff that's
happening there's new giveaway stuff
that I'll explain at the end of the
video too but I'll start with all the
Thor changes they made to the character
that they confirmed will stick during
Avengers infinity board there were a
bunch of things that happened to the
Thor character and people are wondering
are they gonna walk that back there's
been a lot of misleading trailer footage
of the Thor character in infinity war
that makes everything that happened at
the end of Ragnarok really confusing so
we'll start with that then I'll talk
about Deadpool Fox x-men crossing over
with the Marvel movies but just careful
for spoilers for everything in Thor
Ragnarok if you haven't seen the movie
yet starting with what happened to
Thor's faze you know very surprising
moment in the film given that it wasn't
in any of the trailers Thor loses his
eye during the film it's almost like
somebody took the trailer footage like
whatever they used to cut that put it
into Photoshop and they just pasted a
big wound over one of his eyes so that
he looks like Odin now they just did
alternate cuts of the movie for the
trailers so that it wouldn't give away a
big spoiler like they're just trying to
avoid spoilers which also explains why
Thor has both of his eyes during that
comic-con infinity war trailer because
presumably that happens like right after
this moment here where Thanos big ship
comes during the post-credits scene so
it gives you a really good idea for how
much they can change an actor's
appearance in post-production
but if you're not a big Thor comic book
reader he did lose his eye in the comics
the older version of Thor pretty much
looks exactly like Odin so it just sort
of bringing that to pass like he is
taking the mantle of Odin as king of
Asgard so visually they want to make him
look a little bit more like Odin but
obviously he has the short haircut he's
the god of thunder not the
of war like Odin so effectively all of
the cosmetic changes to Thor are going
to stick during infinity war in Avengers
4 yes I know Doctor Strange could
totally reverse him losing his eye with
the time job like he could literally
just localize the effect and he would
get his eye right back but if you're
wondering why they wouldn't do something
like that it's because you know him
losing his eye is a big marker of his
journey it's a reminder of everything
he's been through of the growth that
he's experienced and if Doctor Strange
gave him his eye back it would be like
them taking back all that character
development it's the same reason why
they haven't told the other Avengers in
the movies that Coulson is still alive
the hammer is going to stay in pieces
like Thor basically said that he's not
going to get the hammer back during
infinity war he said that he gets a
brand new very cool weapon didn't say
what it is but we've seen some concept
art for it so because it sort of reaches
out of the frame it doesn't completely
reveal what it is and because he said
that he's going to remain hammer less I
think they're just going to give him the
axe that he will did during the unworthy
Thor comics so it's just speculation but
yarr Bjorn is just like the next coolest
weapon and he's been using it for the
last couple of years in the comics the
big change for Loki's character is that
he has come around a little bit more
he's a little more sympathetic but that
doesn't mean that he's a good character
he's still primarily interested in
self-preservation remember how he tried
to turn Thor in while they were escaping
sorry but this is the better option so
he still loves his brother he still
cares about the Asgardians my people
your savior is here but he's not above
throwing people under the rug in the
name of self-preservation which is why
he pocketed the tesseract really the
only other big change is obviously the
destruction of the physical location of
Asgard that's not going to come back
they're gonna Bree build it in Norway
they'll probably wait till Thor pops up
during a phase four movie to address
what's happening with it like oh we're
still in the middle of rebuilding Asgard
the name of the actual city is just
called as Gardea or if you want to go
with the collector's name you can just
call it a sperg rebuilding new ass burg
on earth that feels like a joke that
Tony Stark would make if then I think we
could all agree that hella escaped to
parts unknown
at the end so she's off floating in
space somewhere until she gets picked up
by somebody but really the most
important things to remember is that
Thor still has his power because that
comes from Asgard in Asgard as a people
not a place so as long as the Asgardian
people still exist Thor will still have
his special lightning abilities that you
saw during Ragnarok
but now moving into Marvel Disney x-men
crossover so if you don't know why
people were freaking out this morning
it's because there was a report that
Disney is in talks with Fox to buy most
of their entertainment properties that
includes all the movies stuff in most of
the TV stuff but not everything but that
would mean that they would get the film
rights to the x-men characters back
Deadpool is an x-man character so they
get the Deadpool stuff as well but as of
right now me posting this video talks
have stalled out a little bit but
because it's such a big billion dollar
negotiation that's totally normal like
they're gonna go back and forth maybe
they'll end up buying them maybe they
won't if they do I will totally do a
video but there's not much point in
speculating about legit x-men Marvel
crossover because until they sign that
deal it's all vaporware but what will
probably happen is is Fox would continue
to exist as its own film unit within
Disney the way that Marvel and Star Wars
are two completely different companies
like Lucasfilm does its own thing Marvel
does its own thing but at the end of the
day everybody gets paid by Disney so
Disney sort of just sits there as this
umbrella that owns a bunch of different
brands Fox would just become another one
of those brands people have been making
the false assumption that just because
Disney would buy Fox that means that
they wouldn't do Deadpool movies anymore
because Disney typically doesn't do
rated R films that isn't totally correct
if Marvel wanted to do a rade at our
film they could do that it's just that
they haven't found a character that
would benefit from that the way the
Deadpool did like it would be really
hard to sell an awesome version of
Deadpool that was pg-13 the people at
Disney the people at Marvel they love
making money they're not stupid so if
the formula for Deadpool is what Fox has
been doing so far they're not going to
change that formula it's just that at
the end of the day the people that
distribute the movie in the title card
at the beginning my
change a little bit everything else
would stay the same but Disney buying
Marvel is how you get your Wolverine
version of The Avengers it's how you get
Deadpool to crossover with some of the
more comedic Lee inclined characters the
director of thor ragnarok said that he
wanted to include a Deadpool moment but
of course lawyers aren't gonna allow
something like that but now you could
actually legit do some sort of Deadpool
thing in a Marvel movie however big or
small you wanted to but let me know in
the comments if Disney does end up
buying Fox what do you want that
crossover to look like do you want to
keep them separate or do you actually
want to see x-men characters go up
against the Avengers so flash day is
tomorrow I'll have new infinity war
coming later this week but there's a
bunch of DC stuff happening I'll explain
when I start posting those flash videos
but there's a new round of the Thor
ticket giveaway you can actually use the
gift certificate for any movie that you
want because Star Wars is coming up all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the winner from the
last video Bruce Allen please private
message me so I can get your contact
details you can click here for all my
Thor Ragnarok Easter eggs and you can
click here for that brand new Star Wars
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight
you